ed a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovi dio sono fatti j
ed oggi siamo su uno dei più grandissimi
giochi che potrete mai vedere nel resto
della vostra vita lo scopo principale
visto gioco è quello di comandare una
una capra una capra un che regga parto
subito perché sono sono esagerati lo
aspetto da mesi e sono troppo curioso di
vedere di che cazzo si tratta perché non
ne ho la più pallida idea quindi
proviamoci play play to play vediamo che
cazzo esce fuori perfetto posso già
muovermi siamo già a perfetto siamo
siamo già partiti così come cazzo si
gioca dato che i comandi non li so è una
cosa già un po vera nobs takle si fa
così perfetto ragazzi sono sono riuscita
a saltare è male però va verbi potrebbe
esserci riusciti come cazzo fate la luce
perché c'è un'altra capra tu mi stai
solco la è una è morta dai ragazzi
vediamo se riceve andare in giro da
qualche fate perché già mi sta prendendo
il casinò quindi [ __ ] a noi cos'è
questo intrappoli l'impiego e figlio
guarda che trek
guarda video ma è normale una cosa così
non so con quale legge fisica una capra
potrebbe mai fare questo non è norma
solo chiodo in piedi 30 lei voleva
vedere un bel trucco di di ok perfetto
come non detto
non so frenare ragazzi non so parola
dove riuscire a capire come cazzo
aggiungere 5 metri in altezza si sta
roba tra l'altro qua dentro
no ho preso cosa ho preso posso sparare
le cose ma fa ancora marito e tutte
mariuccia tu che cazzo marrazzo
vecchiato tizio ma perché la gente
sviene se viene colpita da una pallina
devi morire
oddio ragazzi ma che cazzo sud ma perché
è perfetto ragazzi ci sia allora direi
che possiamo andare in giro siamo pronti
è una casa la perché questo mi è morto
perché questa si è beccato un pari in
testa ma se io ti pole aiuta sia realtà
c'è solida stronzo non lo vedi che sono
in mezzo alla strada che cazzo ti
investe a mio di area e non c'è neanche
da neanche più a sono vivo sono mia
investito una macchina ma sono vivo
senza signora è il chelsea come se un
tizio che passa in strada io la
l'accompagno fin qui e poi mi lavo dai
[ __ ]
ci vediamo che cazzo succede da te che
sono qui vai vai dai grandi che anche il
cammino anche ai camion perfetto vai
così finito allora tu non mi piace
io non ti piaccio e allora [ __ ]
permesso di mercy e per mia figlia mi ha
distrutta ha devastato
ma io posso lega ma che cazzo ma io
posso leccare le cose mariga ma se
voglio attaccare la mia lingua la
macchina a posto s'è visto la faccia ma
no kat
rega aiuto aiuto ma quanto è dico non ci
possa andare alla addio perché già su
cerm i ragazzi che cazzo sta succedendo
sono in mezzo dove siamo dove cazzo sono
finito su un tetto posto le carico di no
no cazzo ma no ma perché una capra
maltratta fissi ma verve grande così
grandissimo o la mia lingua che attacca
ma per chi è ma perché mi sono
scaraventati ma fermi sono finito in
mezzo al nulla perché a ci sono le
macchine da rally per una brutta stronza
ferma credo riuscirà ad attaccarmi pure
a te enac ha fatto questi allora ci però
ci provai così mi sono attaccato pure a
questa fantastico arriva al bolide
arriva il mali ovvero ho beccato un
pizzo dove scappa ma io posso per può
sopportare le macchine cesta lingua
riesce a trascinare le macchine
rendetevi conto se io le metto qua in
mezzo 2000 dei [ __ ] no per ogni dove
non è normale che una macchina faccia
così tanti disastri ci metto sto tizio
in mezzo voglio dire che cazzo succede
perfetto ed a buttarne giusto perché c'è
una lingua elastica
nega fantastico fantasma fermati o
possente macchina fus e non ha
funzionato giustamente uno di cuore
impressionante finale dei mondiali
si no ho sbagliato sono uscita sbagliare
a porta vuota live marzo live baggio è
fantastico ragazzi ma non è normale che
una capra riesca a leccare più cose di
miley cyrus anche anche i camion vai
così perfetto ma tanto ormai ho battuto
ogni tipo di recco ragazzi e fantasma e
finisco sempre nei campi non si sa
perché anche c'è anche il benzinaio
fanello così se io riuscissi tiguan era
esattamente quello che volevo fare
c'è un deltaplano mica fantastico lo
voglio buttare giù subito accertato
ragazzi c'è una scalata si mostra salire
le scale si possa come capo un quale
cazzo di criterio fisico una capra
potrebbe mai fare questo ragazzi ci siam
mica il punto più alto madonna è
fantastico voglio vedere se riesco a
buttare giù deltaplano dai caa
buongiorno vorrei che cazzo ci fa qui
ragazzi c'è un tizio non so se non vada
giù si levi dai [ __ ] questa è la mia
gru per il distretto da dice lo schema
al par4 mancato di brutto a tuo figlio
di una capra fuori budget
no ma era impossibile ai cazzo dai cazzo
cat mario velo pupazzi l'ho preso
l'opera è caduto ma no non è calma
vaffanc ebrei caduto no coughlin state
studios perfetto non si può entrare ma
si deve presentare alla porta quadri ma
[ __ ] rientrano alla finestra chi
se ne fosse ce ne sono in casa sono solo
bussato molto gentilmente è fantastico
perché perfetta insomma le care anche i
tabù per madonna sono entrato un minuto
sono entrato già in disastro è una capra
domestica ragazzi e fantastici grande
perché ci sono delle slot machine in una
casa non è normale buongiorno è lui che
lavori seriamente sentimi infatti darà
una mano io me ne intendo guarda qui
d'oro questo cazzo di gioco potessi fare
così anche a scuola è fantastico è nata
guardali arriva un video ragazzi sta
ancora scrivendo e non è normale
gestione e tu che cazzo guardi no mica
bellissimo si può portare a tv si può
guardare la tv posso giocare a flair
piggott
no non ci voglio credere
ragazzi c'è flipboard solo su glock
simulator ma non voglio crederci questo
è fottutamente epico nava cazzo sono
morta al primo che professionista un
punto l'ho fatto già vabbè 2 il perfetto
3922 mib a st e stato un piacere se non
mi dispiace ragazzi io esco perché ho
finito il mio lavoro qui e fuggevoli fi
come i veri gentlemen trovato soli ma
sono rimasto appeso alla finestra
giustissimo c'è la peek cos'è questa la
fattoria ci hanno fatto una fattoria in
sto gia voce ma i conti cosa ci sono in
un gioco così non è possibile
fate un barbecue e non mi avete invitato
stronze è una cosa che non si può far la
prima regola se c'è un barbecue in di
tifavi geri ok ok non hai capito non
sarà non scappate via mi dispiace che ti
sei preso un palo nei gioielli di
famiglia ma tu sei una donna non centro
ieri di famiglia andata bene ma che
cazzo malate dovete togliervi dai
[ __ ] questa è la mia proprietà c'è
uno scivolo hanno messo un cazzo di
simco i mate razza si è solamente a
scivolare su sto coso lega al mio tre
urlo di guerra
vai così fantastico voglio vedere che
cazzo succede bye bye bye alla madonna
madonna che cazzo mi chiama e normale
che un trampolino riesca a far questo
non è anche ha centrato la piscina me
fantastico passeggero clandestino su un
camion
io vi giuro che non ho mai provato ma
mai provato un gioco così senza senso
lo dico se ci sono anche i fuochi
d'artificio cioè fantastici se ovvio
aiuto sono anno perché sul fuoco dati
oddio santissimo sono slogan tasti co
sono esploso sono caduto in mezzo a un
recinto sono fantasie bellissima cosa
cazzo succede perché sono diventato la
capra elastica per distruggere tutto
quel che cazzo vedo è una cosa e ragazzi
sto gioco qualsiasi cosa può essere
distrutta a [ __ ] i tavoli tutto dice
madonna che bella sta a casa
mi verrebbe proprio voglia di entrare
dentro e spaccare tutto e cosa mi
trattiene esattamente c'è una coco dio
stanno mangiando tranquillamente ma non
per molto a buongiorno ragazzi sono
state mangiando molto tranquillamente
che cosa romantica mi dispiace se mi
unisco a voi cos'è fanta bellissimo che
goduria giunta perche un tapis roulant
ma se io mi metto su sti cazzi e vabbè
madonna 9 ragazzi su ciò che come primo
episodio fatto un po di di collage di
tutti i momenti più strani perché dovevo
riuscire a capire più o meno di cosa si
trattava luca ragazzi in gioco e
spettacolo
non ho mai visto una cosa così strana
però non importano ragazzi ha concluso
filo episodio come al solito ragazzo il
video è piaciuto lasciato argomento mi
piace anche a pagina di facebook con a
divido tra tra descrizione e selezione
prescritti iscrivetevi noi ci rimettiamo
in un prossimo video bella ragazzi